[Music]
let's go back to washington to spokane
and talk to my new best friend mary
what's up mary
oh oh
one of those
yeah
and donna
i don't even know
hey
i don't even know what's going on but
i'm so grateful that you called what's
up
so
[Applause]
thank you
it's great to talk to you um it's better
to talk to you
i've been
together with my current well only
spouse for the past nine years we've
been married for eight
and
um
eight of those years there's
been abuse going on um gosh what kind of
abuse
all of them okay
and
uh we have two kids
and things really
um
really got bad a few years ago
when um
when
our daughter went through a challenging
time and she needed weekly counseling
that i took her to and it was just
it was hard on everybody but i was
trying to get her healthy
so um
drinking started
happening more frequently
with you or your husband
with him
and
i've been with the same
personal counselor
this entire time
our kids have the same counselor
and so they know all of it
some reporting has happened um
are kids safe
yes
are they watching things are they seeing
things happen to their mother they
shouldn't be seeing
yeah okay
um
the physical stuff has not happened
since
about seven months ago six months ago
when he um
last did it but
was never you know on the brink of
uh death or anything
but he was arrested
he did get arrested
yeah
okay called 9-1-1 he got arrested he was
charged
and there was no contact order in place
um
and then he got another charge
and now he's on probation
but for some circumstances
he's now
he's i'm sorry this is hard no of course
it's hard take your time
um i've been making plans for quite a
while um to leave him but i haven't
really found the strength to do so
because my parents had
the world's nastiest with a capital n
divorce
and
um
it was
terrible and i don't really remember
much
from my childhood
because of my own
assault that was happening at that time
but as i'm kind of peeling back those
layers more memories are coming back and
i can't i just i don't really remember
them married
but what i do remember the most is
how alone i felt when my parents did
separate
and
although i've i've made the steps i've
never really made that big leap to
finally been be done and move forward
with my two kids
our two kids um
but i did have the conversation with him
early last week
um
and i told him i was done and
in the first time
for the first time in the last
eight years
he wasn't defensive
or
denying
that anything has happened
but i don't trust that this
is going to last because he usually does
um
he's usually good for a week
maybe
mary
you know
so i guess i'm just really trying to
figure out um
because a lot of words were thrown
around last week that have kind of
thrown me off which is
i i'm the one wrecking the family
yeah
you know
yeah
you know
you're worth more than all of this
and there's a moment now
where you get to for the first time in a
decade
finally love yourself enough
to scratch and claw yourself back to two
feet
and say i'm worth more than this
and especially these two little babies
are worth more than this
there's no words
there's no i promise you
there's no you have a baby this time
it's
10 years
10 years
your parents
divorce is not your separation
your body remembers that trauma my guess
is
a lot of your childhood trauma got
pinned on that divorce
what do i mean by that
my guess is
my guess is it probably is not as bad as
you remember it the actual divorce
my guess is it got wound up in a whole
bunch of other stuff i may be way wrong
on that
but my guess is there was a lot of abuse
going on a lot of trauma going along a
lot of screaming and yelling and stuff
that terrified a child
that got pinned on
and i say pinned on our bodies just do
this man um in trauma trauma screws up
our memories big time they got pinned on
the divorce process
oh
and my guess is it wasn't that
and
hear me real clear when i say i'm about
to say okay
okay you can do the right thing
and it still hurts like hell
leaving leaving an abuser
someone who i mean just listening to
your language he hasn't done it in six
months and he's out of jail now and he's
saying
and i was never really close to death
all of those things are ways we just try
to make
what we have happened to us okay so that
we can just keep stumbling forward
and you deserve more than a stumble
forward life
and so this is the end of an era end of
a decade this is end of a fantasy you've
had this end of a picture this is not
what you signed up for and it slowly
became what you're the hell on earth
that you were living
all of that's gonna hurt
when you finally say no more i'm worth
more than this
it's gonna hurt bad and that doesn't
mean it's the wrong thing
if you have a heart blockage they have
to break your ribs and open your chest
up to fix your heart it hurts and it's
right
just like this
okay i think i'm doing it more so that
the kids could see that i know i know
but you because and if you have to do it
for the kids fine
but i'm telling you
you're worth doing it for you
nobody deserves to live in the horror
in the fear and i can't sleep and my
body's not my own body
yeah nobody has to should live like that
careful
nobody
but i also know after a decade of living
like that it's hard for me to even look
in the mirror and say believe that
your body feels it right now as i'm
saying it i know it does but
it's hard to even believe it cognitively
so fine do it for your kids
but you and me my friend mary
do this for you
because you're worth this
and when i say you're worth this here's
what you're worth
can you imagine just falling asleep at
night and sleeping all night
can you imagine getting to decide if
you're gonna have sex or not
can you imagine not getting hit over
something stupid like you bought the
wrong beer or whatever
or you forgot to pay a bill
that's what i mean when you're worth it
you're worth going to sleep you're worth
laughing
you're worth wrestling around with your
kids and not having to worry the house
out of place or whatever's going on in
your home for the last eight years
so hear me say this
there is no more conversations
conversations have been had
and you know as well as i do
the
my guess is he is a master at lobbing
emotional and verbal grenades at you
that will cut to your core
and we'll cut back to that little girl
who's still trying to fix her parents
marriage from way back in the day still
wondering what she did to deserve the
abuse that she
you endured as a child am i right
yeah yeah that crap wasn't your fault
you're you're a baby girl man
should not have
happened
and your body's trying to solve it now
and
this is how these things happen
generationally some guy finds somebody
who's still trying to solve it and he
tries to be that solution
it makes you crazy
okay
okay
here's what i want you to do today i
want you to write that little girl a
letter
i want you to write you when you were
nine a letter
will you do that
yeah
and i want you to let her know that
she's a sweet little girl and it's time
for her to go play
because the adults in her life suck
and they've hurt her for too long and no
more now grown-up mary's back
and we're gonna start turning stuff
around
and now little girl mary can go play
okay will you do that
yeah do you have somebody to walk
alongside you during this it's gonna be
hard this guy sucks
maybe yeah
so hear me say you can't do this by
yourself okay mary you gotta have
somebody to walk with you
okay all right
have you called a lawyer already
yeah okay hey i've had one retained
he doesn't know that make sure you go to
the next appointment you promise me you
won't skip the next appointment
promise
like i don't have one scheduled so i
feel like that's a little bit one one
will come up one will come up and then
you're going to be talked out of going
or you're going to talk yourself out of
going
and that's where having somebody with
you that's going to be your
accountability partner that's going to
go with you it's going to show up with
you it's going to call you and be like
nope because everything in your body is
going to want to skip this part
yeah
and you got to go
you just told me and all 11 of our
listeners
actually we've got millions you just
told millions of people
that you're in
and we're walking alongside you and
we're walking with you
i'll say it one more time you my friend
mary are worth being loved
you're worth going to sleep
you're worth laughter you're worth joy
you're worth people being patient with
you you're worth screwing stuff up and
figuring out and having somebody laugh
with you and walk alongside you
your kids are worth all that too